When you perform the initial installation of Burpsuite Enterprise Edition, you probably
chose to run the Enterprise web server and Enterprise server on the same machine that
you run scans on.
However, putting too many concurrent scans on the same scanning machine can cause performance
issues.
In this case, you might want to deploy one or more dedicated scanning machines to ease
the load on your Enterprise server machine.
The setup process for a new scanning machine uses the same installer that you used for
the initial installation of Burpsuite Enterprise Edition.
However, you might need to download a different installer if your intended scanning machine
uses a different operating system.
On the machine you want to use, log into your account on porttwigga.net.
Under your licenses and products, download the installer for the same version of Burpsuite
Enterprise Edition that is installed on your Enterprise server machine.
This is also available from our downloads page.
Open the installer and follow the same process that you did when installing Burpsuite Enterprise
Edition.
When asked what you want to use the machine for, deselect running the Enterprise web server,
and Enterprise server, and select running scans.
When prompted, enter the hostname or IP address of the machine where you previously installed
the Enterprise server.
External scanning machines automatically access the Enterprise server on port 8072.
When the installation is complete, you are given a fingerprint of the scanning machine's
public key.
You need to keep this to authorize the new scanning machine later.
Log into the web UI as an administrator and go to the scanning machine settings page.
On the authorization request tab, you should see a pending authorization request showing
the IP address of the new scanning machine.
If you are using a standard deployment, as opposed to a Kubernetes deployment, choose the pool that
the scanning machine will belong to.
Compare the public key fingerprint shown with the one that you saved after setting up the
new scanning machine.
If they match, click authorize.
The scanning machine is now available for use on the scanning machine settings page and
you can start assigning scans to it.